uh we do have a discussion forum where
more than 21
000 of our viewers and listeners are now
subscribed it's all free
davidpakman.com reddit a few
uh posts and topics of interest that i
spotted this morning that i do want to
discuss with you
user stelo14 posted the white house has
announced trump will resume
coronavirus press briefings why was
there a hiatus and why are they all of a
sudden coming back so
essentially the the answer to both
questions is sort of the same
except the perspective was changed the
hiatus started because the white house
wanted to portray coronavirus as being
over
so one of the ways to portray
coronavirus being over is saying we no
longer need to do daily white house
press briefings
the press briefings were also doing
damage in the sense that
at one of the last ones before the break
donald trump wondered out loud about
injecting hitting the body
as he says with isopropyl alcohol
and bleach to treat coronavirus disaster
and so the idea was let's stop the
briefings in order to help trump
by pretending coronavirus is over that
didn't work
and the first wave never ended and now
we are actually back to over a thousand
deaths a day we are at 60 70 000 cases a
day maybe in the direction of a hundred
thousand cases a day
so for the same reason because things
aren't going well trump is going back to
try to improve his approval he
stopped the press briefings to try to
improve his approval he's now restarting
them to try to improve his approval and
it has been sort of a different trump
that has shown up
saying uh you know masks are important
taking the mask out of his pocket which
he keeps with him as a prop all the time
now
saying it may get worse before it gets
better a very different tone than we
have 15 cases which will soon be zero we
now have by the way
4.1 million cumulative cases
so i don't know whether this will make
an impact at this point it may be too
little too late but the reason that
there was a hiatus
is the same reason that the white house
coronavirus press briefings
are now back also from the david pakman
show subreddit user katie all the time
posted what happens if many refuse the
coronavirus vaccine
should it come out saying right now dr
fauci says getting hurt immunity
might not be possible due to our
anti-vaxx
anti-science and anti-authority
sentiment
unfortunately he is right
you're going to have to convince people
who may normally be pro-vaccine
uh but are scared the vaccine was rushed
through
this is a serious issue i mean there's
no other way around it the united states
is uniquely dropping the ball on
coronavirus
and it's not that anti-vaxx is only
present in the united states
but there are some big enclaves of it
here and
the level of immunity you need to get
hurt immunity varies based on how
contagious
something is so for example measles is
so
contagious i think it has a reproduction
value and r naught of
i think it's somewhere between 16 and
18. and when something has a 16 to 18
are not
you need like 95 percent of the
population to be immune to be vaccinated
in order to have heard immunity now
coronavirus is not as contagious
as measles of course but at
coronavirus's level of
of spreadability of contagion the
estimates are you need about 70
immunity now we're only at like one two
percent from people who have recovered
from the virus and we don't even know
how long that immunity lasts at this
point
so you are going to need a lot of people
to get the vaccine and some significant
portion has already said they probably
won't so i don't have a solution but
this user on our subreddit is correctly
pointing out
that we may be up against a real problem
here if and when the vaccine is
available and if and when we determine
that the vaccine
creates a sturdy immune response
the anti-vax movement and some people
who are just going to be worried because
of hey
this vaccine was developed quicker than
any other vaccine
maybe it's not safe even though of
course safety trials are
like the first hurdle that it has to get
through i don't have an answer
unfortunately katie but that that is
likely to be a problem
uh join the discussion at
davidpakman.com
r-e-d-d-i-t